We have a voicemail number.
That number is 2 1 9 2.
David P. The egg man called and we haven't
heard from the egg man much.
If you're not familiar with the egg man.
The egg man is a former federal convict who
did some time for completely nonviolent drug
charges.
Remember that?
Nonviolent.
He's a good guy and he calls in every once
in a while.
He believes that Joe Biden will crush Trump
in Florida.
Here's why he believes that.
Hey, Dave, I love when you have Bill share
on.
The guy is great.
He's super smart.
He's dead right about Florida.
Florida is definitely going to vote Biden
over Trump.
I have two reasons for this.
The first reason is when Trump was a New York
resident.
New York did not vote for him.
Okay.
But understand that New York is far more liberal
than Florida.
So, so far, it's not a great argument from
the man.
But let's continue.
Who rejected him?
We voted for Hillary.
Now that he's Florida's problem, as inbred
as they are, Florida is going to reject Trump.
I'm telling you, this is going to be just
so he may be right.
But Florida is just a redder state than New
York.
So I don't know that it's a good comparison.
If you know, if if Trump moved to Massachusetts,
Massachusetts isn't voting for Trump.
So I don't know how much the residency is
going to be a factor.
Okay.
Also, my dad is an old Jew in a retirement
community and they all love Biden.
They don't give a crap about any allegations,
anything terror of who they are voting by
them.
They have sex baby tests that are chicken
and they're going to have eggs in a chicken
coop this year.
Sometimes one turns out to be a rooster.
If I have a rooster, I'm going to name him
after your brother David Pakman.
But hopefully I won't follow my brother high-power.
Right.
Shalom to the egg, man.
And yet, by the way, the rooster thing just
reminded me I've been getting some videos
from viewers of their pets who like watching
the show.
So there's a Portuguese dog.
I don't mean a Portuguese water dog like the
breed, just a dog in Portugal who watches
the David Pakman show every day with rapt
attention.
And I got a video of it and a bunch of people
if we're gonna do a compilation of these.
If you have a pet that likes watching the
David Pakman show, please get video of it
and send it to me.
We would love to see it and include it in
our upcoming compilation on the bonus show
today.
Republicans are now trying to win that California
special election that we've talked about many
times before.
I'm going to talk to you about that.
We will also talk about U.S. grocery costs.
We often talk about deflationary spirals when
we talk about recessions, possibly depressions
like the one we are in or may soon be in.
But there.
Are areas, elements of society where we have
seen significant inflation of prices.
Groceries are one of those areas.
We're going to talk about that.
Also on today's bonus show, the Georgia governor,
Brian Kemp, now says Georgia drivers who got
their licenses without a road test are going
to have to eventually take that road test.
I want to talk about where this all came from
and the implications.
Don't miss today's bonus show for our members.
Only sign up at join Packman dot com or at
Patry on dot com slash David Pakman show.
Huge bonus show.
I will be joined by producer Pat Ford and
there will be much discussion, very much talking.
I will put it that way.
The David Pakman Show at David Pakman dot
com.